i've been talking to you for a long time
over the years and i've always loved it
when you come on the program
and i realized that the question my
producers
and i think everybody always wants to
ask you is the same question over and
over again and you must be getting sick
of it
which is you've been married you and
kevin bacon have been married for you
know
so many years how do you keep your
marriage happy
what's the secret and i think do you do
you just ban that question now from
interviews
no i don't because um you know i have a
funny answer and the
and the answer as does kev kevs is
you keep the fights clean and the sex
dirty
oh people like that one right and mine
is
the secret to a happy marriage is not to
take marital advice
from um celebrities yes that's mine
is to not not not ask me that question
because i don't have the
but the true answer is and i'm just
going to tell you right now
the secret to a happy marriage is not
hanging out together
24 7 365 days a year
yeah i mean like you know
absence make the heart makes the heart
grow fonder and like
you know when you're out in the world
and bringing things back into a marriage
that is a good thing
as long as it's not a third person
unless you're into that stuff
which i am
we'll talk about that later i don't know
if you guys have this but like
as we've been married like our bed has
gotten bigger
you know like like we started out with a
queen for like 20 years we've been
married 32 years and like
21 years in the marriage kev's like i
think we need a better bet
bigger bed and i'm like what a bigger
bed
you know this just at the beginning of
the end i mean i was like really freaked
out by it but then we got a bigger bed
and i was like oh yeah bigger bed
that's good you know what you should try
this is something my wife wanted to try
about two years ago we got bunk beds
so i'm on the top she's on the bottom
there's no physical contact
she doesn't want me touching her um so
it's the top bed in the bunk bed
and then the utility closet during the
day and we have a very that's how you
keep a marriage going that's the secret
yeah i don't know why bunk beds are just
for kids
it's ridiculous